رجل بلا درجه علميه ولا حضور سياسيه او
منصب الرسمي لكنه قد يكون صاحب النفوذ
الاكبر في ايران بل ربما ان سلطته احيانا
تجاوزت المرشد ذاته فمن هو مجتبى خامنئي
الذي بدا اسمه متداولا في الاوساط
السياسيه مؤخرا
هو الابن الثاني للمرشد الايراني
وتلقى تعليمه بمدرسه العلوي بطهران ولكنه
ترك الدراسه في سن السابعه عشر
خلال فتره رئاسه والده لايران في
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي وعندما اندلعت
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه حمل السلاح
ليقاتل دفاعا عن بلاده في صفوف كتيبه حبيب
بن مظاهر التي يقودها حتى الان
في المشهد السياسي اول مره عام 2009 حيث
اتهم بالتدخل في الانتخابات الرئاسه لصالح
محمود احمد النجاه
المرشح الرئاسي مهدي كروبي في رساله
لوالده
كما التهم بقمع الاحتجاجات التي رافقت تلك
المرحله وقتل فيها 36 شخصا على الاقل
قدم مجتب نفسه كمنقذ وحارس لوالده اضافه
لاشرافه على اعماله التجاريه لكن دوره قد
يكون اكبر من ذلك بكثير حيث وصف برجل الظل
للمرشد في ايران
ومجتمع الذي يقل وجوده اعلاميا له صولاته
وجولاته في الظل فهو يمتلك نفوذ واسعا في
اجهزه الدوله بفضل مكانه والده فيجتمع
بالمسؤولين المحليين والدوليين ويتخذ
القرارات ويعين رجالات الامن وهناك شواهد
عديده على تدخلاته فبحسب شهاده المفتشه
سابقه بالاذاعه والتلفزيون
يتدخل بالسياسه وتشكيل استخبارات الحرس
الثوري الايراني وله سلطه على فيلق القدس
الرئيس السابق للاذاعه والتلفزيون عبد
العلي علي عسكري كشف ايضا ان مجتب اجتمع
بنو وبوالده لترتيب التغطيه الاعلاميه
لحادثه مقتل قائد فيلق القدس قاسم سليماني
واجراءات التابيين في مكان المرشد نائما
ورغم انه ليس مسؤولا امنيا فانه الشخصيه
التي هتف ضدها المحتجون على قتل شرطه
الاخلاق لمهسا امينه كشهاده منهم على دوره
في المؤسسه الامنيه مسؤولون امريكيون
وايرانيون اكدوا ان نفوذ خامنائي الابن
شمل العمليات العسكريه
والاستخباراتيه الدوليه وقوات المسيد كم
امتدت يده للحوزه الدينيه في ايران حيث
منحته المؤسسه الدينيه رتبه ايه الله وهي
المكانه العلميه التي تؤهله لمركز المرشد
وفيما جري من تداول انباء عن تدهور الحاله
الصحيه لخامنا الاب البالغ من العمر 83
عاما
تتزايد المخاوف في اوساط المعارضه
الايرانيه من تنامي نفوذ مجتمع
فمن وجهه نظرهم ان الاخضر من سلطته اليوم
انه قد تم تحضيره لخلافه والده وهو ما يعد
انقلابا على مبادئ ثوره قامت لالغاء حكم
ملكيا استمر الفيصل